another incredible moment during
yesterday's committee hearings the
january 6 trump riot committee hearing
was when a rioter showed up
said he regrets everything and explains
that he was duped by trump we're going
to be looking at video here of of uh
january sixth writer stephen ayers who
testified to the january six committee
under oath
and one of the fascinating parts of this
is we've had this vague question were
the rioters really paying attention to
what trump said so the the defense
that's often made is listen
a lot of these people
they came from far away to washington dc
it couldn't possibly have been what
trump said at noon
that made them go and riot at 1pm and of
course this is a very short-sighted
analysis it's barely an analysis because
the um the the sort of incitement to
that event started well before january 6
but we're actually going to hear from
ryder himself stephen ayers tells us
during his testimony yeah you know if
trump earlier had said go home we would
have gone home we thought that's what he
wanted us to do so let's go to the first
clip uh how did he end up there and does
he still believe the election was stolen
because remember the the reason for the
rioting was the election was stolen by
joe biden and we've got to take it back
stephen ayers was asked about this
interesting answer you know that's
basically what got me to come down here
and do you still believe the election
was stolen
not so much now um i got away from all
the social media
when january 6 happened
uh basically deleted it all
you know i started doing my own research
and everything and
for me for me
for something i mean his own research
got him into this problem in the first
place but okay it's still interesting to
listen to that to be that
actually for that to actually take place
it'd be it's too big you know there'd be
there's no way you can keep something
like that quiet
as big as something like that
you know
with all the you know all the lawsuits
being shot down one after another that
that was mainly what convinced me
so this is someone who either has been
coached or is willing to see reason i
mean everything he's saying is
completely true the problem is we knew
all of this on january 5th of 2021
60 lawsuits went nowhere that
information was available on january 5th
before anyone decided to show up before
anyone actually showed up and write it
maybe they had decided already the fact
that such a conspiracy would require so
many moving parts and so many people to
be involved it was election officials
and uh precinct monitors and state
officials and federal people
coordinating and the people controlling
the machines we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines yeah that
analysis was available to steven ayers
on january 5th so listen this guy
is in trouble he potentially has been
coached but it's still interesting to
hear what he had to say now later ayers
testified that when trump said on
twitter it's time for you to go
they decided to go they were as far as
they believed doing whatever trump
wanted them to do tweet i believe that
included a video telling people to go
home
did you see that and did that have any
effect on what you were doing
when we were there
as soon as that come out everybody
started talking about it and that's it
seemed like it started to disperse
you know some of the crowd obviously
you know once we got back to the hotel
room we seen that it was still going on
but it definitely dispersed a lot of the
crowd and did you leave at that point we
did yeah we left
so in other words that was
the key moment when you decided to leave
when president trump told people to go
home yeah yep we left right when that
come out
so very clear
they were there because of trump and
when trump said go home they left very
hard to argue that trump had nothing to
do with this
he actually said stephen ayers did later
in his testimony
if trump had tweeted to leave earlier
they wouldn't even have been there in
the first place
um yeah i think everybody thought he was
gonna be coming down um
you know he said in his speech
you know kind of like he's gonna be
there with us wow i mean i think i
believed it
yeah i understand
um
we know that you illegally entered the
capitol that afternoon and then left the
capitol area later on what what made you
decide to
leave um basically when president trump
put his tweet out we literally
left right after that come out
um
you know
to me
if he would have done that earlier in
the day
1 30 i i you know
yeah we wouldn't be in this
maybe we wouldn't be in this bad of a
situation or something
whatever you think about stephen ayers
whatever his intentions are now and
listen i'm right there with you this guy
has every he's going to tell us in a
moment in the next clip his life is
ruined he lost his job he had to sell
his house that
he has an interest in portraying himself
as the reformed clear thinking former
trump guy who denounces everything
no question about it
it's abundantly clear
that they were paying attention to what
they believed donald trump wanted trump
made it seem like he was going to march
with them down to the capitol steven
ayers testified to that as well all
right last clip here
ayers says this has ruined his life
and that makes sense do we feel bad well
you tell me i mean
if you believe in personal
responsibility he made these decisions
looking back on it now how do you
reflect
on the role that you played in the crowd
that day and what is going on in your
life
um
basically you know i lost my job
since
this all happened you know uh
pretty much sold my house
um so
everything that happened with the
charges you know thank god uh
a lot of them did get dismissed because
i was just holding my phone but at the
same time i was there
um
so i mean it definitely it changed my
life you know uh and not for the good
definitely not for the you know for the
better
um
yeah i mean
so whatever your thought is on how
honest stephen ayers was in the
testimony or whatever else
the important things here are number one
these people were genuinely duped by
trump and the people around him now we
can say we don't care we can say they
deserved it we can say that it was their
responsibility these are adults i'm with
you
but they were duped by trump and so the
idea that trump was an irrelevant player
here absolutely untrue secondly
the idea that had trump called them off
earlier they would have left at least
steven ayers is saying of course we were
we were following what we understood
to be donald trump's direction and that
is another key component here so a
fascinating day
and it is expected that next week
there's going to be another blockbuster
day of testimony uh which we will of
course be covering for you on the
podcast and potentially live as well let
me know your thoughts about steven ayers
as a witness smart to bring him not
smart did we learn anything or not i
think it was an absolutely great
decision
some people emailed me said i didn't get
the point of this testimony oh i got the
point the point was was very clear
and uh i think it was a good decision
let me know you can find me on twitter
at deepakman we'll take a quick break
and be right back i think this is the
biggest discount that any sponsor has
ever offered on the david pakman show
this is crush organics crush organics
loves the show so much
they're giving my viewers 50 off their
entire collection of organic cbd
products when you use the code pacman
i'm the only show
where you can get this big a discount
that i like and for each sale crush
organics will donate ten dollars to the
last prisoner project that's a really
great non-profit helps to
free non-violent drug offenders and
reform drug laws very important and it
doesn't stop there anyone who uses my
code also gets a free jar
of cbd gummies or a jar of cbd topical
cream crush has only the best organic
cbd whether you're looking for oils
creams or edibles so that's 50 percent
off and a free jar of gummies or topical
cream and 10 bucks towards creating real
change in our justice system go to crush
organics dot u s
and use the code pacman the link is down
below